hey guys in this video I want to talk about
ketosis and constipation now I wish it was
real cut-and-dry that it would always be this one
thing but it's it's usually a complex thing that
could involve multiple things so I'm just going
to go through some of the scenarios that that
come up most people think it's a lack of fiber
that causes constipation that is absolutely not
true in fact a lot of the fiber that people
consume even from vegetables it's insoluble
which means it's not digesting so adding more
will actually constipate you more so if you look
at what you did before starting this plan and
after we want to look at the big changes and we
want to evaluate each change and I'm not talking
about constipation you had before doing ketosis
that's a whole different situation which involves
probiotics and a bunch of other stuff I'm talking
about after the ketogenic diet you started getting
constipation what do you do what do you look at so
we're going to look at the change in vegetable
fibers okay the microbes live on fiber they will
get overwhelmed easily if you have not adapted
these microbes to this new way of eating so just
like keto adaptation you have to look at the
adaptation of the microbes that have to evolve
and grow to digest all these fibers because if
they can't digest the fibers you're going to have
this all this cruciferous or kale shaking you're
going to bloat you're going to get gas if that's
happening then you're going to have to change
the vegetables that's simple too maybe something
like like just lettuce spinach other types of
vegetables romaine lettuce something like that
to get your greens so just definitely look at that
other people have an issue with certain types of
cruciferous like myself I can't eat broccoli it
tears me up it will constipate me I can do lots
of cabbage other people cannot do cabbage they can
do broccoli so you're going to test it out I also
recommend fermented vegetables simply because
those are much easier to break down and pickles
are good sauerkraut kimchi very very good okay so
we have that and then we also have you know just
the fat that you're eating the protein in most
cases those two types of macros are easier to
digest then the vegetable carbohydrates believe it
or not but it could be that you're doing too much
fat that's plugging up the gallbladder and that
is backing you up so if we look at just the whole
digestive system you have the ability to digest
fat proteins carbohydrates or or even fiber and
just you want to just check each one of those so
so things to adjust our the vegetable the type
of vegetable may be too much fat and the other
thing is that when you start a ketogenic diet
you will sometimes lose a lot of water weight in
the process lose a lot of electrolytes so that's
why I always like to add that back in there I
highly recommend the electrolyte powder that I use
because it has a thousand milligrams of potassium
it has magnesium and as all the electrolytes and
trace minerals no sugar that usually will help the
elimination greatly so even potassium in general
is the electrolyte to help with muscle cramps and
colon cramping or stagnant colon so when you have
more potassium and helps facilitate elimination as
well as magnesium those two are electrolytes that
are really important elimination on a very rare
occasion I may have the person make more water
but typically that's very rare that's not usually
the cause but it's something to look at if you're
eating drinking no water you know that could be
a situation but it's rare the other thing is that
if you're doing too many nuts or even some seeds
which it's usually nuts or peanut butter typically
if you're doing raw nuts you're doing you're
getting enzyme inhibitors which means that that's
going to stop your digestion right there that
could be causing the constipation so an experiment
would be to germinate the nuts soak them overnight
draw them out in the oven on to lower temperatures
and then consume them and you may find that that's
also a problem the other thing is just to cut out
the nuts for a couple days and see if that gets
rid of the constipation because that could block
and it also has insoluble fibers so you've got the
combination of enzyme inhibitors and then you just
can't digest the nuts the enzyme inhibitors and
then as far as dairy goes so quite a few people
are have allergies to milk sugar lactose okay so
that's the situation and you're bloating or you're
not digesting this cheese that you're consuming
we got to look at that as well so just kind of
experiment if you have some dairy and you get
gas or bloating then we need to eliminate that
at this time there are types of dairy that are low
in lactose for example lactose free cheese lactose
usually cheese has very low amounts of lactose
because the microbes consume that sugar and then
they they basically you get more of a protein
than you would get if you had actual milk or
yogurt casein is the protein in dairy which that's
really high in hard cheeses and it's also lower in
soft cheeses it's higher in Greek yogurt so you
know if you're consuming too much of that protein
that could back people up as well back you up so
you might want to try try goat's cheese or sheep
cheese which people can digest that much better
than actually cheese from cows so you might want
to try that as well so these are just things
to look at in your search to find a solution
for constipation put your comments below hi guys
hey listen I created a pretty amazing evaluation
quiz down below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root cause
of all of your symptoms the most likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you report